have you ever had to break your family's
rules today I'm breaking mine around
money secrecy and shame in 2006 on my
brother Kees 40th birthday he called Tam
I'm in dire straits
I wouldn't ask unless I had to
can I borrow $7,500
this wasn't the first time II need a
quick cash but this time his voice
frightened me I had never heard him so
beaten down and shameful and it was on
his 40th birthday after a few basic
questions that we would all ask I agreed
to loan him money but under one
condition
that has the financial professional in
the family I wanted to meet with him and
his wife to see what was really
happening weeks later we met at the
local Starbucks and I started right in
with the tough-love budget conversation
you should sell the house downsize to
something you can afford sell the toys
and Starbucks give up the $5 a day
coffee you know all the trappings that
we do to keep up with the Joneses
quickly my brother and his wife went
into a fierce and blame game and it got
messy I've a slated between therapists
and pissed-off sister I wanted them to
be better than this come on you two get
your [ __ ] together
your parents grow up and buck up after
we left I called my mom but Keith beat
me to it and he told her that I wasn't
helpful in fact he was hurt and felt
ganged up on
of course he did I shamed him with my
tough love budget conversation two
months went by when I received a call
Tam
I have bad news Keith committed suicide
last night
days later at his home I went looking
for answers in his office the garage
there I found a stack of overdue credit
card bills and a foreclosure notice
served to him on the day that he died
my brother left behind his beautiful
ten-year-old daughter his brilliant 18
year old son weeks before his high
school graduation and his wife of 20
years how did this happen
my brother was caught in our families of
money shame cycle and he was far from
alone in this suicide rates among adults
ages 40 to 64 have risen nearly 40%
since 1999 job loss bankruptcy and
foreclosures were president nearly 40%
of the deaths with white middle-aged men
accounting for 7 out of 10 suicides what
I've learned is that our
self-destructive and self-defeating
financial behaviors are not driven by
our rational logical minds instead they
are a product of our subconscious belief
systems rooted in our childhoods and so
deeply ingrained in us they shaped the
way that we deal with money our entire
adult lives and so many of you are left
believing that you're lazy crazy or
stupid or just bad with money this is
what I call money shame dr. Brene brown
a well known shame researcher defines
shame as the intensely painful feeling
or experience of believing that we are
flawed and therefore unworthy of love
and belonging based on this definition
here's how I'm defining money shame the
intensely painful feeling or experience
of believing that we are flawed and
therefore unworthy of love and belonging
based on our bank account balances our
debts
our homes our cars and our job titles
let me give you a couple examples of
what I mean I believe that we all have
money shame
whether you earn ten thousand dollars a
year or ten million and it's because we
give money all of our power here's what
it would look like if someone that you
love or you might have money shame they
play the Big Shot always picking up the
check financially rescuing family and
friends they are financially secure but
they live in a state of chronic not
enough Ness
they drive a Mercedes but their budget
really only can afford a Honda and
they're looking good at every cost I
know that we can break free from the
grips of money shame because I did
shortly after my brother's death the
recession hit I lost my business and
faced bankruptcy I secretly I was
terrified I stayed in my home for a year
thinking I did something wrong
told myself what did you do what
happened
I stayed silent while all along I went
outside and smiled
nobody knew that's money shame so what I
had to do was let go of the grip that I
had on knowing all the answers
I was the know-it-all in my family and I
had to give up the idea that a new
financial plan was the solution and so
just like everything in my life for me I
was sent a human to help and I accepted
the help but I had to do major self
inquiry about my family
money history and my money beliefs we
have to start having this conversation
money can no longer be a taboo topic we
have to get honest with each other
that we're suffering with money issues
and let's get real we have to stop
numbing out our pain in order to uncover
the painful parts of your money story in
your money history you can't be numb we
have to let go of our past in order to
be free letting go of the past happens
through surrender faith and forgiveness
debt is the tangible manifestation of
not forgiving if you have debt you've
not completely forgiven your past so
it's our work to forgive ourselves and
others so that we can live freely
otherwise our history will continue to
repeat this is not a quick fix and I
know we all want one but it's a slow
wake up this is another level of work we
have to go higher to get it to get at it
so try this follow your dollars your
money will show you right away what you
value where is it going and then ask
yourself do I really value all this
stuff and get curious about what you're
feeling when you're spending are you
lonely are you bored or are you just
excited
but there's deeper work that needs to
happen how did you get all these money
beliefs to begin with I call this your
money autobiography and as a money coach
this is the first step I take with my
clients think back to your earliest
childhood money memory what did it feel
like when you got money were you excited
proud
or confused and what did you do with the
money did you run to the candy store
or did you run to the bank and what did
you hear your parents say and what did
you see your parents do with the money
my brother and I heard more money will
make us happy every day more money will
make us happy and we internalized that
into the money belief that our
self-worth was equal to our net worth as
we watched our mom live in a state of
chronic not enough nasheed unde the pain
with sugar and shopping so what did we
do Keith played out my mother's life he
was an under earner longed to be
financially rescued and he numbed out
the pain with alcohol I did the opposite
I became a high earner rescued rescuer
and I numb the pain out with self-help
books but what we had in common was our
money belief we both believe that our
bank account balance was equal to our
self-worth looking back at the Starbucks
meeting with my brother he didn't need a
budget in my judgment he needed a
breakthrough from his suffering and he
needed my compassion keith was not able
to be the one to speak up and break our
family money shame cycle so he left me
to do the work and share his legacy
change is difficult but my family not
changing is fatal so I did the work and
I have experienced deep and profound
forgiveness and as I stand here today I
am living on purpose I serve and money
serves me it only takes one person
your family to break through the money
shame cycle I want you to be the one
thank you
[Applause]